[Music]
good morning welcome to day three of
next 2018 my name is Eric Schmidt I'm a
developer advocate in the Google cloud
platform team you can reach me on
Twitter at not that Eric if you were
expecting the other Eric Schmidt I
apologize
hopefully you're in the right room
this session is architecting live NCAA
predictions from archives to insight you
can also reach me at cloudy cloud with
an e at Google calm
you want to have a private conversation
outside of Twitter how many of you have
ever built a house or remodel the house
or know a friend whose remodeled a house
or build a house this is a picture of a
house every model a little while ago and
I was trying to figure out how to start
the talk and I realized that this is a
great way to set context for what this
talk is about building a house is really
hard and without plans and without a lot
of communication a lot of different
tools and collaboration you more than
likely fail fortunately through a lot of
trial and error I'll show you a picture
maybe later about what this ended up
looking like but can I keep this in mind
as you're building something it's
important to have a foundation it's
important to have a plan and a lot of
patience this is one of my plans what's
this talk about this talk about is about
three things
it's about NCAA and basketball it's
about the Google cloud and it's about
predictive workflow specifically for
live TV advertisements how many people
are into basketball how many people are
into cloud predictions wow we have a
pretty good ven here this is great
awesome I'm gonna walk between these
three concepts
jumping back and forth it'd be awesome
to do this talk linearly but it would
also be impossible and it most of what
I'm going to share with you
are things that happen to myself and
several other several meaning 15 to 20
people in real time in real life and I'm
going to share with you some of the best
practices that we learned and applied
along the way real quickly since this
talk is about the NCAA if you don't know
who the NCAA is it's important to
understand so the NCAA is the governing
body for collegiate sports and at the
end of the day their mission is to help
be an integral part of higher education
for college student athletes and to
provide an environment for them that's
safe productive and helped build some of
the most amazing championships on the
planet how did we get here how did this
talk happen how do these ads happen back
in December of 2017 Google cloud became
the official cloud provider for the NCAA
the NCAA is has a lot of kind of typical
challenges has a lot of challenges of a
typical enterprise although people may
not think of the NCAA as an enterprise
but the NCAA manages hundreds and
hundreds of schools times the number of
sports thousands of sports it's just not
about basketball
football baseball soccer etc they have
decades and decades of competition
information and student athlete
information this partnership was
grounded in helping the NCAA build the
future of their analytics platform to
help them understand and more detail
potentially what's happening with some
other sports and some of the
competitions and areas that they may
have had a blind spot to or they wanted
to get more insight into the campaign
was know what your data knows they have
lots of data but there are areas that we
wanted to dig deeper one of those was
supporting the development of a refined
championship selection process so kind
of looking like how our team selected to
be in some of the championships that
manage so the partnership started in
December kind of based on these three
ideas how many of you are fans of March
Madness okay
now that for some of you that didn't
understand or know who the NCAA was
March Madness is a championship
tournament that happens every year
guess what month it starts in March
there are 351 NCAA Division one schools
that compete for a spot to participate
and the 64 team tournament there's a
women's tournament and a men's
tournament this talk is primarily
focused on the men's tournament so you
have 351 teams they all are vying to get
into a spot into this into this
tournament the NCAA oversees the
selection process so which teams get in
and then how they're seeded into the
tournament that process is very
data-driven primarily using historical
game data to make decisions about what
teams deserve the right to play in the
tournament
Google Cloud as part of this fantastic
Madness around March Madness we decided
that we were gonna build six live
television ads to run during the final
four games anyone want to guess how many
games are in the Final Four
three so so we ran two ads one for each
game and this is the journey that we
took to build out these live television
ads let's take a trip how many have you
been to Austin Texas not Austin how many
of you been to the Alamo dome yeah so
April 2nd 2018 there was a a truck
sitting right about here and the
national championship game was going on
inside of this building
this is me right there I'm only self
identifiable by my gray hair so we're
watching the game and as soon as the
clock hit zero zero at halftime we build
an ad that didn't exist prior to the
clock going to zero zero from scratch
and we ran it live on air predicting
what would happen in the second half so
kind of immerse yourself in being in
this truck this truck is roughly ten by
twelve it's super hot it's filled with
about 13 people watching a game that
about say 80 hundred million people are
watching I don't know how many people
watch the game a lot of people and we
have to go run an ad by the way this guy
right here is one of my main partners on
this project and he doesn't look too
happy right now but let's watch an ad
what did we build
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so that ad ran roughly four
minutes into the beginning of the game
turns out possessions are pretty
important in basketball because you
can't score if you don't have the ball
turns out pace is super important in
basketball because if you're behind you
need the ball in order to score so 130
possessions is that good is that bad and
isn't a lot we'll find out but that was
our that was our estimate that was our
prediction so how did we go from
building in that ad running that ad
sitting in that truck how did we get
there this is the overall architecture
that we ended up building so we started
building this late November early
December right around the start of this
relationship with the NCAA starting on
the left hand side we have raw data
starting and then finishing on the right
side we have a television ad voila we're
done we're out know there was several
pieces that we had to put together and
we're gonna walk through this left to
right now if you're not into product
logos and you think more in terms of
kind of workflow and tasks this is a
different way to look at this talk so
we're going to talk about orchestration
and subject matter expertise business
requirements etc you're gonna see
several probably 15 of these green
slides these are best practices if you
take nothing away from this talk try to
remember what's on these green slides I
showed you the architecture step one if
you're gonna go build something like
this a form a team of discreet subject
matter experts people know people who
know what they know really really well
and also know what they don't know our
team effort looked like this we're
basically two kind of camps of folks
I'll call them the techie people and the
non techie people so the left column we
had a a tech partner lead someone who
worked closely with the NCA and other
technology groups
we had a a gentleman on the team who is
a deep deep NCAA basketball expert we
had folks that just did data engineering
some folks that just did software
engineering some people work wants other
people were just focused on data science
and machine learning engineering then on
the business side we had a business
partner lead again folks were working
with the NCAA working with Turner etc
people writing copy making sure that
what we were doing was on brand that the
ad process was working writes PR folks
legal folks and ultimately some editors
and one of them's in the audience today
so you have this collection of people
and the reason why I point this out is
I've worked on probably a hundred of
these projects and I'll always ask who's
your data engineer and the data science
guy or girl says we don't have one that
that's kind of me I just I just do that
on the side like how much time are you
then spending doing data engineering
versus actually doing data science work
and you start getting into this this
challenge of not being able to focus on
the things that are - really really good
at now that's not to say that it's okay
to kind of cross over but if you're
trying to do something really big make
sure that your staff to appropriately
around the the disciplines that you need
in order to be successful and as you'll
see like there's no way that a single
machine learning engineer sitting in one
of our data centers by themselves could
pull something like this off without a
ton of other support next one and I
promise you you'll see some code here
soon the next one is write down business
requirements scope as soon as possible
and communicate with precision so that
group of technologists talking to the
group of business folks in the beginning
it was hard for us to communicate
because we weren't writing down things
we're like oh yeah we're gonna build
these ads what do you mean we're gonna
build ads how many didn't need to build
when do they run how fast they need to
get done etc and then iteration is key
so decisions that we make today or
decision that we made say made today
three days from now one of them likely
we're gonna tweak that based on new
inputs both from the technology side as
well as the business side
so how do we get to business
requirements these were these were words
that I distinctly remember in meetings
you can kind of guess which ones maybe
come from the business side versus the
technology side right so people say like
hey we want these ads to be delightful
like cool what does that mean right and
then the folks in the technology side is
like how how precise do we have to be
and then the legal guys would be like
don't be too right but don't be too
wrong as one of the leads on this
project I was always thinking is like is
this even feasible like like can we pull
this off like so we wrote a bunch of
documents and we started to get very
crisp and clear about what a lot of
these words meant from there we started
to narrow down scope as it means to
start building a predictive work flow so
we had some team rules so first and
foremost does have to be on brand so I
had to feel like Google it also had to
feel like the NCAA had it be contextual
had to be about basketball had to be
about the game that was happening had to
have mass appeal like I wanted to run
ads that were just around dunks but
turns out not everyone likes dunks and
then we had this idea of Goldilocks
outcome so it couldn't be too hot and it
also couldn't be too cold and then we
had a bunch of other things like don't
be - basketball II it needs to feel
delightful and then by the way all this
system that we were building on the
workflow side needed to be executed in
under two minutes so everything else
aside as soon as that clock hits zero we
have two minutes to basically hand off
information to our creative team to go
build an ad then we finally got to this
wrote this down and printed it on my
wall and then didn't sleep for four
months which was build X number of
real-time predictions to power the
development of six television ads each
of these have to run in under ten
minutes from start to finish like for
them to getting traffic with Goldilocks
accuracy while being prepared for
hundreds of game scenarios how many of
you knew who was going to play in the
final four games or championship games
whenever the tournament started cool all
right a lot of honest people in this
audience so how did we get there
step 1 collect data step 3 ads that's a
joke from South Park it's probably too
old but so we're gonna work left the
right as we were building out this new
analytics workflow for the NCAA we got
very close intimates
with the data that they had and we're
talking about decades and decades worth
of competition data at the same time we
also worked with a data provider called
sport radar they are a provider of
real-time sport information and they
also support the NCAA as well as Turner
Broadcasting and the reason we worked
with them is they have real-time
information about what's happening on
the court with versus the majority of
the NCAA data is all historical in
nature so step one collect data how many
of you love XML alright I wrote the
first one of the first XML partner
parsers at Microsoft about 15 years ago
I thought it was the best thing on the
planet it turns out that there are other
encoding formats that are a little bit
better but historically we had to deal
with tens of thousands of these files
that represented what happened in these
NCAA games some of them are 15 20
thousand lines long how many of you love
JSON all right
slightly more than the response from XML
still fun format a little bit easier to
deal with the challenge here would be in
both cases what happens if you have
missing data what happens if you have
malformed data tens of thousands of
these files as well for us to just
understand historically what happened
with all the games inside of NCAA
division
basketball so what did we do we went and
started to build a process to look at
the NCAA's data as well as sport radar
data it just wasn't about games we had
to look at schedules we had a look at
rosters we had a look at reference data
like locations box scores play by plays
ultimately we were sitting on around a
hundred thousand files all different
types of schema by the way the women's
game has different roles different
timing than the men's game so we're like
oh great and then we had appealed to
different systems at different primary
Keys across this data different ways to
pull it so ultimately we had to build a
workflow
around our data engineering process so
next best practice treat data
engineering as a first-class citizen in
your overall workflow I see this kind of
get kicked to the side a lot like oh
yeah there's some folks working on that
over there oh they'll handle all the
ingestion and transformation and also
ingestion is a function of data
engineering so just even acquiring the
data can be an extremely difficult
problem next one and this is what you'll
see what we built is as you start
building out your ingestion and
transformation workflow build something
that is repeatable and automatable just
because you're you can go download a
couple files using some you know HTTP
JSON hack together implementation
doesn't mean you can do this repeatedly
over and over and over again potentially
thousands of that times at scale we used
Apache beam and then you'll see here in
a minute
cloud dataflow to drive the majority of
our ingestion and transformation process
this stuff can be a little boring
because most people just want to get to
predictions but as you'll see this is
probably one of the most critical
sections and building out your workflow
is being able to ingest and then
transform that data into something
that's actionable so we leveraged Apache
beam and then wrote a
series of ETL pipelines that said go out
pull X so Y is spaced from the NCAA for
certain schema types do some
transformation on that JSON and or XML
and then ultimately load it into
bigquery
the third point about avoid inline
mapping you'll see this in some of the
code I've noticed sometimes people will
say oh well I know that this game ID
over here or this value over here Maps
just directly to this column over here
so I wasn't gonna do is just read from
here and write to there try to avoid
inline mapping whenever you're doing
this because ultimately something's
going to change in your system either on
the database side or on the input side
so come up with some type of common type
system that you map to and Apache beam
provides an excellent environment for
you to create a type system whether
you're in Java Python etc we're also
writing this data to a cloud storage
it's a spanner into some other sinks
because we needed the ability to
interact with this data in different
types of environments so it's another
benefit of us using Apache Beam in this
case is we read from one source but then
we're writing to multiple sinks so let's
go ahead and ingest all of 2016 here's
the code some of the code that I wrote
the pipeline code I don't make this a
little bigger it's pretty
self-explanatory
so an Apache Beam I'm gonna go write a
transform that knows how to go read from
a particular source in this case all the
boxscore summaries and then I have a
summary parser that knows how to take
that JSON or XML convert it to a Java
type and then I have a writer and in
this case my summary writer ends up
splitting a single input into three
different tables so I have a summary
about the game
I have a summary about the players in
those games and I have a summary about
the scoring for those games and the
beauty of this is is I can kind of rip
and replace one of my outputs I can push
it someplace else I can add another
output if I need it
and after I stitch all of my transforms
together I go ahead and hit run I could
run this locally but I would blow up my
machine because we have tens of
thousands of files here but I could do
that you know test on a few but let's go
ahead and run this in the cloud so it
hit run and the command line is going to
package up all my Apache beam code call
out to cloud dataflow kick off a job and
start reading all my files for the sake
of time we can go look at what this
looks like in the console so if I go
ahead and look at this here is a view of
one of those jobs so I have the first
step was basically loading my summaries
then I have my parser then I have my
writer we ran these jobs thousands and
thousands and thousands of times and
that's the beauty of building a a type
system and then leveraging something
like Apache Beam or another ETL
framework in order to get this work done
great so we just ingest 2016 a lot of
our focus was around the 15 years prior
to this recent March Madness we're
constantly kind of going back and
pulling in 15 years 15 years 15 years
now that we have some data let's start
doing some exploratory analysis next
best practice this one I stuck to you
pretty hard if the data wasn't in
bigquery it didn't happen we had lots of
conversations with folks on the team
like I found the super cool data or this
feature and it's really great and Mike
where is it well it's on my laptop or
it's in the CSV file or having a
spreadsheet it's over on GCS I'm like I
don't care bassam bigquery it didn't
happen so consequently folks were
looking at well how do I get data into
bigquery I don't want to go write a big
Apache you know beam job fortunately
bigquery has a nice UI I can just go and
say go ahead import CSV import Avro etc
and get data into bigquery let's look at
some data in bigquery that we loaded up
this is probably the simplest one to
look at this is looking at the total
count of games by year for Ben's
Division one basketball I ran this one a
lot just as a verification like smoke
test like yeah there's roughly five
thousand nine hundred and seventy-one
games in a year doesn't really tell you
much but it's a good audit process and I
had all types of different data outputs
from my apache bean jobs or those
one-off jobs in our bigquery project
the query just showed you is I don't
know not very helpful so I'm gonna show
you an another query which was something
that as a team we quickly realized was a
very available thing to do which is as
we found things that were interesting we
rented them as views and then started
sharing them so instead of just having
some static sequels sitting around and
source control somewhere is like hey I
have a view it has something that's
interesting I'll go ahead and share it
and a lot of these views that their goal
were to do things like grouping by team
grouping by conference doing time series
quantization things that we had to do in
order to basically aggregate data into
something meaningful so if I go here
this query this was one of the original
ones we wrote we were interested to see
is there a difference amongst
conferences there's 32 conferences in
division 1 basketball is there a
difference among conferences in their
home court advantage do you think that
there's a difference among conferences
in home court advantage
maybe I don't know so I write this query
it's interesting it shows me some data
but it's kind of hard to see what what
this really means right so you kind of
have a hunch that yeah there's probably
a difference in home court advantage one
of the nice features inside of bigquery
is I can click on the outputs of my
query and say visualize instead of data
studio and in this case I want to look
at the home point advantage which was
the output of my query and I can quickly
visualize that yes there is a difference
between pac-12 playing at home they're
favored by about four and a half points
on average versus the Ivy League or the
big south or Mac so I haven't built any
predictions yet but I'm starting to kind
of gain
some insight on like what things could
be skillful in terms of building out
predictions say if you have a pac-12
team playing a colonial team during
March Madness keep in mind though that
they're playing on neutral courts so we
have another problem to solve but this
is an amazing way to start exploring
your data by the way data studio is free
and all the visualizations that you
build inside of it or easily shareable
if you've played with Google Docs go
ahead and click share people have access
to your data don't do that all right so
we can explore data in bigquery we built
views to satisfy common use cases we
also spent some time looking at our
audit logs and just talking to folks
like hey what are you building what are
you writing and they're like oh I wrote
this cool query great let's go ahead and
materialize that a viewer as a table so
you stop running the query over and over
again and you get a little bit more
efficient the next thing that we did was
look at some visualization techniques
outside of bigquery and data studio
which is using cloud data lab so cloud
data lab is a a host able implementation
of ipython notebook you can run it
locally in a doctor container you could
also run it on the cloud go ahead and
just use the RG cloud commands to go
create a data lab instance and I have a
fully fleshed out ipython development
environment that is optimized for the
Google cloud and once you're there you
can do something like this I'm in my
ipython notebook make this a little
bigger and I take my big query that I
wrote this is for a different type of
analysis move it over into data lab I
execute that query
it's a fairly big query I pump it into a
data frame and do some visualization so
this visualization was focused on
understanding how players on teams on an
individual basis can contribute to the
three points that a team is scoring so
in this case Kentucky on average has
three players that contribute the
majority of their three their three
point production versus Davidson who has
five different folks who are
contributing to the three point
production so you could look at this and
start to make some inferences like hmm
three guys versus five guys who are able
to produce three-pointers who has the
advantage all right so I can visualize
in data studio sitting on top of
bigquery I can visualize inside of data
lab sitting on top of bigquery by the
way if you go out to a medium calm and
look for analyzing NCAA college
basketball with GCP we have about 30
articles that kind of reinforce some of
the we'll call them like classic
visualizations and and feature ideas
that we were coming up with so best
practice here if you think something is
interesting visualize it if you don't
know if something is interesting
visualize it if you find something that
you thought was interesting and it turns
out not to be interesting visualize it
and share it with the team yeah all
right so now we're gonna go from kind of
exploratory analysis to looking at some
features some things to keep in mind all
351 teams in Division one basketball are
not equal in strength and performance if
that was the case man this would be a
really really hard tournament to pick
pick the teams
but in our case we wouldn't necessarily
know who all the final four teams were
until a week out so as we're thinking
about features and what types of models
we would build we kind of had a plan for
a very very broad set of use cases from
there as we started to drive into our
the features that we're going to use
so then we had to stop and say well what
are we predicting on like we still
haven't gotten there so the
conversations between the the tech folks
and the business folks we came down to
these 28 predictions so we had
predictions focused on single team and
we have predictions focused on combined
stats between teams and then we also had
these predictions around game state
focused on close and late and down to
the wire in essence we had to go build
20 predictions for each of these games
across these categories so this is the
the the number of predictions and then
looking into those kind of prediction
categories we started looking at well
what's interesting what makes 3-point
attempts interesting or possessions
interesting so before you saw up there
it was said 130 was the estimate for the
number of position and possessions so on
this slide we looked at the the
distribution of all these stats across
2017 Men's Division one basketball and
it turns out you know 130 possessions
would be roughly around the 50th
percentile down on the bottom now keep
in mind this is across all teams we
don't necessarily know who's going to
play in the championship game or Final
Four but this gives you some indication
about what is interesting where would
those numbers fall if you were looking
at all teams so the next thing to do was
we knew which kind of prediction in
categories we wanted to go after we knew
potentially what was interesting then we
had to figure out well are we going to
use forget what type of modeling
techniques we're going to use here we're
going to use regression technique so
we're gonna use classification
techniques so if you're new to this this
is a real quick slide the idea of
regression is I'm going to take some
input variables and then output some
continuous variable and the whole idea
is I'm trying to build a function to do
this the magic of machine learning so my
input variables would be all these
different stats and the output variable
would be how many possessions are gonna
be in this game how many three-point
attempts are gonna be in this game from
a classification perspective
again and number of variables and then
output some discrete variable so is this
game going to be closed in late yes or
no so you have some type of binary
classification the question here is what
is X what features should you use to
drive these models this is the hardest
part this is like saying like I had some
funny things to say but the like it's
like where do babies come from like like
we kind of know where babies come from
but like the process is there's all
different types of things that happen
and like how do you stitch all of these
things together in order to create some
type of successful function and this is
the whole process of doing your feature
exploration and feature engineering so
going back to our data we started
talking to folks and say ok we have data
about conference and seasons and games
and players and segments etc oh by the
way we're not using one tool we're using
tableau and Jupiter and our studio and
collab etc but everyone was able to
rally around using bigquery as the
center of truth for the data you want to
use our studio awesome rock easy
connectivity to be query your in collab
go for it everyone was looking at the
same data so from here we can then look
at what features could potentially be
skillful this was a model that we wrote
it was a classification feature to see
if a game would fall into higher than
the 75th percentile for a particular
stat I think in this case it was three
point attempts so we would start with
hundreds and hundreds of features and
using different techniques we could
start to look at which features were
most skillful which ones we're going to
give signal to drive a prediction
interestingly enough if you're looking
at three point attempts one of the most
skillful features is the average of
three point attempts by a team in their
last seven games that's an easy one but
you know if you only
had one feature your model may not be
very powerful so we go searching for
more features and looking at things like
let me scroll down here and find one
another one that's interesting you know
free throws the attempt that you know
attempts an elaborate seven game you can
see there's a little bit of distribution
between the these two so there are
different techniques to go through your
feature selection process the point here
is that whatever tool that you're
choosing has access to the same data and
as we were doing our work one of the
guys in the audience was was on the team
we would be saying like hey like in my
process I see that this feature is
really skillful great to go ahead and
put it back into a view so that everyone
can use it so best practice so use views
to help build out your features that
your selecting version them this was
another thing people like a week ago I
had a feature that seemed to be pretty
skillful but now where did that thing go
so use views and just version them
another best practice use sequel as much
as possible to build the aggregations
for your features I had lots of
conversations with people that and they
would say I wrote this wicked pandas
code in an eye Python that extracts data
does a bunch of aggregation and loops
and blah blah blah blah and I have
awesome features I'm like great
could I have that and then they send the
code check it in and I run at my kid
that this takes an hour and a half to
run and 95% of that could have been done
in sequel could we take that process and
put it in the sequel so then I can just
leverage B query to push all that down
and run it in 12 seconds now granted
there are some cases where you can't do
that and you know but if you're not
trying to do it then you won't
necessarily know at what point you need
to jump out of some handcrafted
environment and leverage sequel o other
best practice all engineering artifacts
should live in source control persistent
disks attached to VMs does not qualify a
source control your laptop
that you think is secure it does not
satisfy as source control build a system
get whatever workflow you want to use
make sure you're checking everything in
so it's just not about code it's about
sequel it's about your notebooks it's
about your ideas so we talked about some
feature analysis now let's get into
modeling and make some predictions so we
use five different tools to build out
our models and we use bigquery ml which
was announced yesterday and it was a
lifesaver on this product or on this
project we use scikit-learn heavily we
used XE boost we used
caris and a little bit of tensor flow
again and the whole idea was whether we
were building regression model or
classification model we were using these
tools because these are the tools that
we're helping us build the best
performance not necessarily because that
was the tool that we liked so you'll see
this in a minute true those choose the
tool that works not the tool that you
like to use and I am going to jump over
to the first one that I'm going to show
you is our close and late model how many
of you would like to know if a game was
gonna end it close and late at half time
so you knew whether you should just
leave or stay at home all right okay so
we built this close and late model and
the person that built it did all the
right things they wrote down the
business requirements they were very
very very precise about what this
definition of close and late meant vs
down to the wire man there's all the
sequel that were driving the feature
inputs and talked about what types of
features that matter and then ultimately
we built some visualization to show if
this model would trigger or not so our
minimum threshold for running an
around a prediction was minimum it had
to be 65 percent confident so 65 percent
probability that this was going to
happen otherwise we wouldn't move
forward so at halftime the Villanova
score was 37 Michigan 28 so if Villanova
was up by 9 and if you look at this
graphic Villanova is down here here's
Villanova whenever they're up by 10 we
weren't even close to hitting 65%
probability on this which was awesome
because we knew that this was the
decision we were not going to this is a
decision we were not going to make we
would not predict you know we would not
run this ad so this is close to late and
the sad part is that none of the final
four games ended up close and late and
we did a ton of work and never ran the
ad but it was a lot of fun another
modeling technique that we used was
bigquery ml so now we're back into
bigquery so I took all those steps of
like feature and engineering
visualization etc etc now with bigquery
ml I have the ability to build a model
straight in line and here's the code
basically you say create a replace model
which is a functionally just a view
inside of your data set I go ahead and
select the features that I want to use
so I go ahead and select from this
really really really wide view of
features go ahead and train in this case
I want to build a linear regression
model and it will output a model for me
then to score so I've already built this
model I go ahead and flip through the
other view which is now I want to
predict and I say I need to select from
the game that I want to look at so in
this case it was the championship game
I'm gonna go ahead and pull in all the
stats up through the first half and then
run the query check that this was all
the stats prior right up to the game so
we were trying to predict on total
3-point attempts so our estimate for
that game was 50 sorry the estimate was
forty nine point eight five and the
actual value
was 50 so we had 28 different versions
of these models predicting on all
different stats and we would would run
them in real time for us to then build
out a decision tree for which ad we
would run on TV right so we've gotten
all the way through this process and
we're sitting in the truck and we're
ready to make a decision how did we do
it by the way I can't underscore the
amount of pressure though we were
feeling because we had to deliver an ad
and that's kind of fun so what did we do
we had automation for serving each path
so we had automation for people using
bigquery we had automation for people
that were using tensor flow in some
cases some of our automation was manual
like we had a person whose job it was
we're like okay hey I'm running this
model this is how the thing works here
are the data inputs that I need but the
outputs of all the automation drove
everything into Google sheets it's a low
five Way kind of a low-tech to do it and
it turns out it worked really really
well because we could easily share all
this data with everyone it was we had to
do nothing to build it out other were
other than write some script in our
automation that says okay right now
here's the state of all the predictions
that we want to make pick the one that
feels the best and at halftime this is
what we ended up looking at which is we
ended up picking you know three points
attempt combined at the second half and
with that data we then moved over to
another system so part of this process
for this overall workflow are the ad
agency and creative agency that we
worked with 11 here in San Francisco
built out a an encoding system that ran
on the cloud that could take inputs and
then encode a live ad in around 30
seconds so this is the workflow that we
use so we took the output of our
predictions
put them into the into the encoding
environment and then BOOM outputs an
atom what I don't show you here is we
had a war room of around a hundred
different scenarios that could possibly
be happening it just wasn't around like
three-point attempts it was three-point
attempts and the underdog is winning or
possessions and the favorite team is up
by 50 like we had all these different
scenarios that we had to come up with
because the visualization that you also
that you ultimately see in the ad how to
match the context of the game just
because I could give you a prediction
doesn't necessarily mean it would
resonate well unless the visuals met the
context of the game so with that then we
had that encoded add and we trafficked
it and that was a super fun process
because we were literally on the phone
with the folks at Turner and CBS their
ad trafficking people and said yeah we
got your ad it's gonna run and we sat
there in about two minutes later that ad
was on national television you know
eight minutes prior nine minutes prior
the ad didn't exist the prediction
didn't exist I remember one of the are
we have this verification process to
understand what happened when and why
and I think in one of the ads there was
a like a cat I think on the on the back
of a turtle is that right yeah there was
a cat on the back of a turtle and and
you hear our auditor talking to their
auditor and the lady says yes I can
confirm that there is a cat on the back
of the turtle and and then they hang up
the phone and then the ad runs and so so
another best practice was we implemented
a process the odd audit the chain of
command regarding this is decision
making so as those predictions came out
of the system we were looking at them we
had a whole process to figure out okay
this is good this is bad this reaches
threshold this doesn't etcetera write
everything down who said what when and
then go so especially when if you have
humans involved this is this is a
paramount importance if this could was
completely automated you would still
have an audit log because infrequently
you know frequently something's going to
happen with some automated process you
have
and you need to go fix it so definitely
implement some type of audit process for
this type of flow so how did we do we
had six different games and what we ran
on TV were the implied probabilities for
each one of our predictions so we had an
estimate we had some type of continuous
value that came out of our prediction
models and you can see down at the
bottom or we said second-half total
3-point attempts combined was the
estimate was 24
the result was 24 so we nailed the
estimate the ad that actually ran was we
will see at least 21 of these things at
a 76 percent seventy six point four
percent confidence level and this one
the reason why we did this is that you
know a television ad we couldn't put
things like confidence intervals and
plus minus that stuff in the ads so we
did some work to basically take our
estimate and convert it into a
probability so we nailed that one
we nailed the combined possessions one
total shot attempts we got a little
squirrely there because the Kansas
Villanova game kind of got out of hand
and that's the whole fun of this it's
like you think you know what's gonna
happen in the game and then the game
gets away and you know sometimes your
estimates are off if you want to learn
more about this process we built a half
of a basketball court in the bottom of
Moscone South how many of you been down
there yet all right cool
fill three to come down I can get into
any part of this that you'd like and we
also have a real-time motion capture
system set up that you can see how good
or bad your jump shot is and it's a fun
way to get into data science from a
different angle just looking at scores
like that's kind of fun you can build
live TV ads I mean that's that's okay
but seeing yourself in real time
shooting a jumper that's pretty fun so
with that said I'll stop take some
questions and I hope you have a great
rest of next
[Applause]
[Music]